o boa noite começará com um boa noite e
eu queria começar falando que eu estudei
na ufrj e comércio e turismo urbanismo
da ufrj memorando jacarepaguá
eu achava que eu viajava todo dia até
descobrir que a uerj tem um campus em
resende tem alguém lá de resende
vocês estão aí no meu coração em ainda
mais vocês morar em jacarepaguá bom
ontem recebeu uma mensagem de uma grande
amiga minha
what sabe me desejando boa sorte hoje na
apresentação que eu que eu voltei agora
nessa apresentação que eu vim fazer pra
vocês e aquilo me deixou muito feliz
pela mensagem ali pra mim foi como se
tivesse recebido um abraço mas ao mesmo
tempo aquilo me incomodou e veio coroar
um pouco do que eu vim falar pra vocês
sobre essas conexões humanas sobre que
nos conecta eu sou um gamer
eu adoro jogos online e eu comecei essa
vida lá no final dos anos 90 com esses
jogos de tiro em seu primeiro jogo de
tiro eu estava participando e nesses
jogos tinha um chat interativo onde eu
podia conversar com as pessoas ea pior
incrível e ali você sentia do lado das
pessoas nessas interações estão
inclusive uma vez a gente fez um raio
virtual
depois de uma vitória apertada que a
gente teve no jogo e aí e esse
sentimento 01 reais
naquela época e nos anos 2000 no início
dos anos 2000 final dos dois anos 90
quando começou a ter essa interação de
começou a ter essas possibilidades da
tecnologia trazendo diversas novidades
pra gente conectando pessoas no mundo
inteiro quase que imediatamente
isso é incrível porque a gente
acreditava que aquilo traria essa
identidade virtual traz benefícios para
o nosso mundo real mais conectado mais
dinâmico ea gente dá um flash folha até
hoje em 2016
algumas pessoas acredito que estão aí na
platéia não consegue dormir diante
daquelas a piada not zap sem olhar o
instagram
você chega ao facebook inclusive caí já
nessa cilada uma vez
onde
prometido para mim mesmo que eu ia
dormir cedo só que o pessoal lá só pra
ver os o facebook as últimas notícias
quando vieram quatro horas da manhã eu
estava vendo o impacto da economia
colaborativa em cingapura
super influência na minha vida mas é
essa modernidade que a gente vê hoje em
dia
então a gente tiver essas conexões
acontecendo hoje muito mais rápido do
que a gente imaginava e tem diversas
pessoas ao longo desses anos estudando é
como é que essa comunicação móvel
influencia hoje nas nossas vidas
é incrível como é que esse aparelho
sozinho é tão poderoso nas nossas vidas
hoje em dia influenciado tanto o nosso
psicológico quanto o nosso
comportamental
o mais incrível é que ele não influencia
somente como é que a gente atua como é
que há gente como é que a gente se
movimenta e sim como é que a gente é
trazendo algumas situações que até há
tempos atrás eram no mínimo esquisitas
que hoje já fazem parte do nosso
cotidiano
tudo bem essa ainda é esquisito hoje em
dia a gente não façam isso vai trazer
alguns exemplos
a gente tem os celulares dentro das
salas de reunião onde as pessoas estão
nas redes sociais tendo aquela reunião
a gente tem dentro da sala de aula
também pessoas engajadas no celular
também aquela aula mas já tinha liberado
mas eu tô falando aquela aula que o
professor consegue engajar com o aluno
onde tem essa troca ainda assim as
pessoas insistem em ficar no celular
nas redes sociais e outra situação as
situações do nosso cotidiano como indo
às compras
atravessando a rua está fazendo grande
parte da nossa vida inclusive os pais
que vivem reclamando de seus filhos que
na hora da janta ou do almoço em família
eles não largam o tablet de celular
eles ficam paradoxalmente fazendo a
mesma coisa com os seus filhos e com os
seus colegas
isso é um fenômeno bem recente onde as
pessoas estão juntas mas não estão
conectadas
mas aí você vem me pergunta por que
porque se importa porque isso me importa
bom me importa porque
está perdendo uma grande oportunidade de
vivenciar o potencial humano de ser
humano que existe momentos que nenhuma
palavra nenhum texto numa mensagem
substituir aquele abraço daqueles
momentos onde você está numa conversa
com uma pessoa mas conversas soltas
risadas entre toques que gera aquele
insight para aquela ideia maluca
revolucionária e aí a gente também quer
ficar muito tempo junto
não confundam isso a gente quer estar
junto com a gente quer ao mesmo tempo em
diversos lugares
isso acaba trazendo situações onde você
vai procurar encontrar seus amigos e
passar aqueles um minuto de conversa
inicial todo mundo sem terra no celular
isso é muito engraçado porque isso gera
situações onde você não gera sem
interatividade no mundo offline
então a gente começa a perceber que com
isso a gente perde diversas
oportunidades de troca de uma maneira
mais em humana e hoje entre a geração a
gente pesquisa que existem pesquisas que
mostram que a gente gosta de interagir
com que a gente consegue controlar isso
é tem diversas pesquisas que mostram
isso ea chery tocou uma grande escola
ela em diversas daquela fez ela comenta
que existe um efeito chamado efeito gold
lock e nesse evento gold lock ele fala o
seguinte nem tão próximo
nem tão longe apenas na distância ideal
nesse distanciamento ideal que as
pessoas tentam se encontrar
e aí você vai me pergunta mas com o
problema de você ter uma relação cara a
cara
bom aí as pessoas respondem primeiro uma
conversa cara-a-cara acontece em tempo
real que segundo você não consegue
controlar o que você vai dizer e aí que
está o x da questão nas redes sociais e
nos e mails a gente consegue evitar por
isso que a gente tira diversas fotos
para achar aquele ângulo ideal para a
gente mostrar que a gente quer ser visto
próximo e é isso a gente gera esse
efeito gold lock nem tão próximo
nem tão afastado apenas na distância
ideal de quem acredita que ser que é o
meu eu e essas interações humanas
elas são ricas de aprendizado nessa
desorganização que elas acontecem
é ali que a gente se conhece reali que a
gente aprende um com os outros e quando
vem a tecnologia com a tecnologia que
consegue limpar a gente consegue
organizar muitas vezes até demais
isso a gente está sacrificando conversas
em sites idéias inclusive o mais
engraçado é que nas conversas
a gente aprende a conversar e se a gente
evita essas conversas
a gente está comprometendo a nossa
capacidade de auto conhecimento e de se
relacionar são pilares pedras
fundamentais no desenvolvimento humano
de uma criança
e aí você me diz o seguinte bom tem lá o
meu chefe me bate papos eu juntar todas
as linhas no bate-papo isso não
significa que eu tive uma conversa real
ea resposta brilhante dessa mesma
psicóloga rachel e tocou ela disse que
não porque essas linhas não se somam
quando você junta pedaço de informação
pedaço de texto a gente está gerando
informação boa tarde boa noite e boa
sorte no ped
não que ela não seja importante elas são
super importantes como a mensagem que
recebi ontem mas elas não substituem o
valor real de uma conversa eu sou de uma
geração que nasce no meio desses avanços
tecnológicos
eu nasci sem a tecnologia e hoje ela faz
grande parte da minha vida inclusive o
trabalho com ela
conectando pessoas no modo online
através do modo offline para que elas se
locomover de uma maneira mais eficiente
em qualidade e eu quero dizer aqui
aprendi buscar esse equilíbrio e esse
equilíbrio essencial para que as nossas
interações online
sobressaiam nessas nossas interações
offline cara a cara e aí que entra o
grande papel da universidade
eu acredito que muito mais do que
informação que é super importante para
diversas carreiras
a universidade tem um papel muito
importante de conectar as pessoas e é o
que eu tiro da minha formação na ufrj
hoje que levo comigo só as suas conexões
são as pessoas que reconhecer isso aí
ela me dei e hoje eu conecto com é tem
pessoas de diversas nacionalidades 47
nacionalidades diferentes
o pessoal vai comemorar no que vem cinco
anos de formado lá na grécia uma menina
que está fazendo aniversário mandou e
mail pra todo mundo e tem uma galera se
conecte se reconecta então é muito
importante a gente levar isso para a
vida levar isso da faculdade e aí tem
esse distanciamento tem os prédios
afastados tem os campos 1 longe do outro
que representa esse grande desafio que
essa conexão
mas lembre se da tecnologia que existe
hoje em dia o que facilita essa
mobilidade que facilita esses encontros
como esse aqui
o ted pra que a gente se conversa para
que a gente conheça então a gente leva a
essência no meu ver no meu ponto de
vista do que é a universidade
esse ramo de pessoas ea uerj tem eu dei
uma pesquisada
obrigado pelo material tem 30 mil
pessoas é o universo aqui 30 mil alunos
quase três mil professores
imagine as oportunidades que a gente tem
aqui
quantas histórias podem ser
compartilhadas
quanto às rodas de violão a gente pode
fazer quando as conversas podem ser
feitas
então fica aqui a minha sugestão
conversa em se conecta com a pessoa é
assim nesse diálogo cara a cara porque
no final do dia se nada der certo pelo
menos a gente deu uma risada entre os
nossos mais novos e velhos amigos
muito obrigado